[Music]
hi I'm Mike Seymour from FX guide.com
for wired in the new Robocop the Omni
cop solution to the acceptance of robots
on the USA is to actually put a guy in
the suit in particular injured policemen
Alex Murphy as the first Robocop film
showed us a real actor in a real suit
makes for a very very bulky suit besides
the guy in the suit is meant to only be
part they're having kind of been blown
to bits earlier in the film in other
words he's missing huge parts of his
body so how did they put just part of
actor Joel Kinnaman in a robotic suit
well the producers opted for a very on
set solution given that much of the
character is digital you might expect to
see the now-familiar green or grey
tracking suit this is the kind of thing
that's the familiar trademark of motion
capture well there were some of those
used but only for deploying the e/m 208
walking down the streets of say Tehran
for the character Alex Murphy even
though the suit would be redone
digitally slimmer and sometimes without
an arm the team at frame store in the UK
opted to still have the actor wear a
real and very expensive physical suit
and there are several advantages to
doing this the first is they get
terrific lighting reference and they can
see any sort of reflections or anything
that would have happened in that real
environment
secondly as Joel was first to admit the
suit really helps the performance and
his own acting choices the way I moved
in soon I did want to give it something
a little bit more robotic so when I was
walking I had turned my head first and
then the shoulders afterwards so the
idea is that he is a superhuman and has
very fluent motion you know after all
somebody has to effectively act the
motion of the Robocop suit and having
the actor actually do it means that we
the audience have a more consistent
performance plus the lighting and camera
Department actually have something real
to frame up to onset not to mention the
other actors having something more
realistic to react to so even if you
have to painstakingly paint out things
that aren't wanted sections of shoulder
or hands if you start with more than a
guy in a gray suit you're going to be
better off and thankfully in some of the
shots a lot of the background was
actually also added which makes the job
of adding a digital Robocop actually
sometimes easier sometimes literally
just his face or his chin was lifted
from the original material and almost
everything else was digitally altered so
don't forget to subscribe for more
behind the scenes action i mike seymour
for Wired
[Music]